look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job
i mean you know don't sleepwalk through
life and don't don't say it's all going
to be great
if you find a people who always complain
the others because he needs success
don't hire him don't work him with him
why did you walk back because that's
where the money is so
a lot of people run paypal same reason
wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
best lessons from elon musk oprah
winfrey warren buffett
and other billionaires enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one find your clarity with oprah
winfrey
the angel network i've been on the air
for a long time
but it was the angel network that
actually focused
my internal gps it helped me to decide
that i wasn't just going to be on tv
every day
but that the goal of my shows my
interviews my business my
philanthropy all of it whatever ventures
i might pursue
would be to make clear that
what unites us
is ultimately far more redeeming and
compelling
than anything that separates me because
what had become clear to me
and i want you to know it isn't always
clear in the beginning because as i said
i've been on television since i was 19
years old
but around 94 i got really clear so
don't expect the clarity to come all at
once to know your purpose right away
but what became clear to me was that i
was here on earth to use television and
not be used by it
to use television to illuminate the
transcendent
power of our better angels
so this angel network it didn't just
change the lives of those who were held
but the lives
of those who also did the helping
it reminded us that no matter who we are
or what we look
like or what we may believe it is
both possible and more importantly
it becomes powerful to come together
in common purpose and common effort
lesson number two
innovate with elon musk so this was
x.com was a precursor to paypal
basically
yeah you merged with confinity and it
became paypal
major success yeah it worked out better
than we expected
um yeah um
so yeah uh confinity
so initially confinity and x.com started
out with from slightly different
directions and then converge to the same
point
with with x the thought was to create an
integrated set of financial services
um so that you could go to one place and
do all of your financial anything
and and then as a feature we had the
ability to transfer money or securities
or anything simply by entering a unique
identifier
so like a you know email address or
phone number or something like that
and uh when we demo the system
the hard stuff which was the integration
of all the
financial services uh people would not
be interested in but they'd be really
interested in it and being able to
transfer money using an email address
you know that was actually quite easy um
and so we focused our energy on that
and although it's easy in principle it
uh what gets really hard is
is adding um security while still
keeping it easy to use
so because you know it's like the woolly
lemon quote like why do people
why do i bank because that's where the
money is so a lot of people run paypal
same reason um and and so
you can you can dial up the security to
a really high level but then you're
going to make it very hard to use
um and and so that that was
that was one of the toughest things we
wrestled with lesson number three
don't sleepwalk through life with warren
buffett if you were to do it all over
again you're in our shoes
what industry would that be in where
would you start your own business today
i do the same thing yeah i mean
for one thing i'd be a failure to
anything else probably i'm not gonna
no i mean i've had i had fun when i was
in my 20s my 30s now i'm 86 i'm having
fun
and so i i advise students as much as
possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job
i mean you know don't sleep walk through
life and don't don't say it's all going
to be great
you know i'll do this and i'll do that
and you know i'm just marking time to
get to be older that
i've told people that's like saving up
sex for your old age i mean it just is
not
it it's not a good idea yeah
what are you urging them to do i'll
explain it
guess what i'm talking about that
now it it just
yeah you really want to be doing what
you love doing
and you can't necessarily find it on
your first job right but
don't give up before you find it lesson
number four
use your money with grant cardone if i
sit with a hundred dollars in my pocket
folks there is no economy
if you want to be economic you let money
flow it has to move
you got people in your company managers
and executives that are saving money
they save their money i'm like what are
you doing dude we're saving money
how can you grow a department if you go
home and all you do is save [ __ ]
you know you open up somebody's freezer
and they got ice cream
that's three months old it's got this
much left in
you you got you got diet coke that's
four days old it's got that much left in
it okay you got
ziploc containers you have whole
cabinets of ziploc containers
and little plastic things where you in
case you had some leftover corn or peas
or potatoes you're like don't throw it
away
save that save that that much pork chop
maybe i'll hit it tomorrow see
somebody put this back in here that's
probably elena doing that
there's no reason to put this back here
it reminds me of my mama
reminds me of when i grew up save
everything
it's a terrible product anyway why you
want to save it look at this
she put two apples in here don't put
them back in the refrigerator man
eat them or toss them you're not gonna
go broke
or get rich saving leftovers
what are you guys doing man you got in
your closet that you ain't ever gonna
wear it don't fit you
it ain't fit you in in years
right how many of you got stuff at your
house you could get rid of you're trying
to save stuff
dude how can you how can you have new
stuff come in when you're holding on
to stuff that you don't even use
right so you have to use this it only
becomes valuable
when it's used now the question is what
are you going to use it on
and the other question is why don't you
use it
why are you so compelled to hold on to
it
what do y'all think that is you don't
know how to get more
number one reason i don't your mother
did not know how to get a new
shirt that's why she took so much put so
much
time and energy in cleaning the shirt
you got a stain on
okay you broke a toy your parents got
upset with you
can't believe you did that what did what
man dude
toys are to be broken that's what a good
toy is for
right right i lost a quarter when i was
eight years old and i would have thought
i would have thought my house was gonna
get torn apart because my dad became so
upset about the quarter you're playing
with money never play with money what
are you doing playing with money and
that that that lesson
pounded on me so hard it kept me from
making real money for 20 years
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five look for optimistic people
with
jack ma i like the people who never give
up
and i've been proved this for so many
years
i've seen so many great leaders in the
world in
many many fields those people are always
optimistic they don't complain ah
you know because of this because that no
they
they think they completely complain ah i
was not that smart i did not think about
that clearly so i had to
need to change so if you find a people
who always complain the others because
he needs success
don't hire him don't work him with him
lesson number six
keep trying with jeff bezos as soon as
you're doing something new it's like
being a toddler all over again you get
up you fall down you get up you fall
down you get up you fall down
and so businesses need to do that same
thing they need to
remember that it's not that bad to fall
down
and it doesn't hurt that much uh and
you know when we try things like amazon
web services we don't know that was
going to work
um it has worked really well but it's
the kind of thing that
if it hadn't worked i always tell people
well guess what if something doesn't
work the day we stop doing it all that
will happen is our operating margins
will improve
it won't be that bad and and companies
are get afraid i think most
companies get criticized for experiments
that they tried
that failed but really companies should
be criticized for the omissions the
things they should have tried and didn't
and those almost always go unremarked
and lesson number seven the last one
before some very special bonus clips
is aim for monopoly with peter thiel i
think that
um all if you're his founder or
entrepreneur
what you want to aim for is monopoly you
want to aim
to build a company that is one of a kind
and that it's so far
differentiated from the competition that
it's not even competing
and i think this is the conventional
wisdom is always that capitalism and
competition
are somehow synonyms i believe they're
antonyms a capitalist
is someone who's in the business of
accumulating capital a world of perfect
competition
is a world where all the profits are
competed away
if you want to compete like crazy um
then you should just open a restaurant
in chicago
um and um and uh and i think
the uh the great companies like uh
google sort of the paradigm example i
use
has had no serious competition in search
since 2002
when it definitively distanced itself
from yahoo and microsoft
and as a result it's been generating
enormous cash flows
for the last 12 years now i've got some
special bonus clips that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you just watch a video and you
get motivated the sign says you have a
35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
percent
to 91 percent chance of you following
through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you i always ask
everybody in the company to think
outside of the box to be very innovative
i like to stop people and say if nobody
showed you how to do your job
how would you be doing your job just sit
with that thought
and i'm basically a case study of
someone who did not know
how it was supposed to be done i mean no
one had shown me i'd never taken a
business class
so i i find there's so much
amazing you know creativity that will
surface if you
stop and get off the autopilot that
we're all on everybody's doing something
because somebody else showed us how to
do it but if you really want to create
big change in the world or in your life
it's going to happen when you do it
differently
or you take a risk to do it different
than how the 50 people or 100 or
thousand people before you did it so
really encouraging thinking that way
with inside the company and as we grow
still remaining entrepreneurial
having fun you really need to learn how
to tell a story
particularly with mbas and when i say
mbas i'm really speaking generally to
the group but i'm being parochial
because i can't come up with a general
expression for mba tonight
but i do find that a lot of people
coming out of school focus a lot on the
what we should do
and don't spend enough time learning how
to tell the story
of why their idea brings value to
others the number of storytellers in the
world
is very very small
i don't know what exactly i will do next
in my life
i don't know i'm not sure i don't have
an idea
but i've been spending a lot of time in
the weight room
reading up on the u.s government budget
healthcare costs of debt
and i say that to people and nobody
knows
i'm doing i can't explain i don't know
earlier this week i came up with a way
to explain it
as ceo of microsoft we were
i was responsible for signing on
something called our 10-q
every every quarter you had to publish
it and it had to tell a story of your
company you had to get up in front of
analysts
i didn't do that very well but
nonetheless
i did it well i just didn't do it very
frequently nonetheless you got out every
mo
every quarter you put out a statement
you explained yourself you told the
story what's good what's bad what's
working what's not working
the us government doesn't put out a
quarterly statement
there's no regular story from our
government
about what's working and what's not
working
where cost really is going and where
it's not
what the president is trying to do the
state of the union is a long list
and whether you like republicans or
democrats you still don't get
a simple and succinct story
i started telling people this week i
want to work from publicly available
information on putting together a 10-q
for the government people said oh we get
that
that's a story a story that you can
start
telling and people understand you can
have a brilliant idea for your startup
you've got to become a storyteller some
of you will say i'm not an expert at
telling stories and telling yarns you're
not great public speakers
that is not what i'm talking about i'm
talking about a clear
simple concise way to convey the
value of the ideas that are in your head
i think it's one of the the most under
appreciated skills in business
it's one of the skills that we talk
about we
did talk about explicitly at microsoft
and if i could wish you one one new
capability to go
build it would be the capability
of storytelling you know for me
the decision to become an entrepreneur
wasn't a decision at all
it was a compulsion if you could call it
that
i mean for as long as i can remember
i've always been someone who was drawn
to
unsolved problems to seeing things
as um an opportunity
waiting to be taken advantage of i mean
seriously you know
i was one of those people who even when
i was probably seven or eight years old
you know i had this this kind of way to
make money where i was selling
seeds for you know that you go plants
from like door to door
and for some crazy reason even i found
even that fascinating and i began
experimenting what can i do bundles
can i do if you buy this you get this
and just because i found that whole uh
challenge of getting better at something
um
exciting and that has never stopped
uh of course as i've gotten older some
of the challenges that i felt equipped
to take on were a little bit
bigger uh i began accumulating a whole
gang of people who felt the same as me
that i could draw on to help me
but you know the things that draw you to
be an entrepreneur in fact the things
that make you a good entrepreneur
um really start very early um
or can be started at any time it's it's
an innate thing
there's this inherent conflict in the
system though which is you know are we
trying to optimize news feed to give
each person all of you guys the best
experience when you're reading
or are we trying to help businesses just
reach as many people as possible
and in every decision that we make we
optimize for the first
for making it so that when for the the
people um who we serve who use facebook
and who are reading news feed
um get the very best experience that
they can and that means that
if a business is sharing content that's
going to be useful for them then
we'll show that but that means that if
the business is sharing content that
isn't going to be useful for them
um we may not show that because it's
probably more important that they learn
about their friend who had a baby and
their baby is healthy
so that's an important guiding principle
for how we think about this stuff
and as the um and as the products
continue to develop
there's just going to be more people
sharing more things um
and we're going to continue to try to do
our best at showing the best things that
we can
understanding that there's no way that
we can that a person will ever take the
time to go through every one of the 1500
things
that are shared with them every single
day so that's
but that's kind of how i think about
organic reach and um
you know there are a lot of pages that
are going that are doing quite
successfully and their organic reach is
growing quite a bit because
they're delivering content to people
that they really want um so if you're a
business owner and you're thinking about
how to use
your free page on facebook i would just
focus on trying to
publish really good content that's going
to be compelling to your customers and
the people who are following you
what advice would you have for managers
or
companies that are really working
through change and struggling
let me define creative destruction or
i will use schumpeter's
definition here's the way he put it it
is not
price and output competition which
counts
but the competition from the new product
the new technology
the new source of supply the new type of
organization
which commands a decisive cost or
quality advantage
and which strikes not at the margins
of the profits and the outputs but at
their foundations
and their very lives so that's what
we're talking about here this is
not life or death for us individually
but life and death
for our businesses and our jobs and so
what we do
to communicate this is get all our
employees to understand
that change is a risk for all of us
but not changing isn't a risk
it's suicide it is a certainty
that you are going out of business and
you are going to if you
individual employee if you're not
changing and improving
and working on that every day you're not
going to have your job
whereas if you take what you think are
risks and you find
a way to eliminate most of your job
because there's a way to do this more
efficiently or to bypass
do it a completely different way here at
coke you're not going to lose your job
you're going to be a hero
my son in 2014 gave me a book by joseph
campbell called
hero of thousand faces and basically he
described that
these things happen you know everybody
crashes and
then you're faced with that crash
and you either have an epiphany or you
don't
now you either walk off the field and
say hey i don't want to do this anymore
and you give up on that
going after your audacious goals or you
gain really
humility you you know how do you feel
that you're going to be wrong
and so i think then that whole notion
is um you know to come back with
the um finding the smartest people i
could find
who disagree with me also
i'm in the investment management
business that you have to bet against
the consensus
otherwise you can't make money because
it's in the price and you have to bet
against the consensus and be right or as
an entrepreneur
i'm an entrepreneur i had to bet against
the consensus and be right and so
to gain that humility was the the thing
so you either get off the field or you
learn
no one cares whether you live or die and
that's what that mentality can grow with
that
i'ma get it or i'mma die trying if i
don't try what am i doing
what kind of life am i saving like these
things is wicked in these mean streets
none of my friends speak we are trying
to win
we are trying to win and a lot of times
we bumping heads because we all trying
to get out that's like the crabs in the
barrel mentality
you know that we have because everyone's
trying to survive and they
trying to survive at any cost you have
to look at that you got to look at the
environments and places we live in
and how things are set up and how things
are structured and how we're always the
last on the totem pole even
from our school and to our roads to you
know everything that would that
all the obstacles that's placed in front
of us even our living conditions and
broke is a great motivator
have 26 floors and there's a ton of them
right these low-income houses and
everything is messed up there
so living that's like living dormant
if this if this is like this what i have
to live for
then i'm going to take a chance to get
more it doesn't matter
you know people often ask me what it
takes to start a business
what is the key ingredient how did i how
did i start the business and
how did we grow to about 20 million 20
million dollars in sales so quickly
you know they all come up with some new
whiz-bang idea they're gonna invent the
the better mouse trap they're gonna come
up with new software new hardware
and more often than not it seems like
they've spent their millions before they
they thought through their idea but when
we talk about
new companies and growth and success
there really
is only one common ingredient across
any type of business whether it's oil or
computers or software anything and that
key ingredient
is customers without customers
whether you're starting a business
running a business expanding a business
you don't have a business there is no
business customers are the key
ingredient
to get those profits you got to have the
customers
and you got to have happy customers
that's the bottom line
you know micro solutions we've been
we've been going and growing and it's
impossible not to have growing pains
it's impossible not to make mistakes we
screw up all the time
and you know it doesn't bother me as
president if i ever if i have an
employee
you just didn't do something right just
made a mistake
it's good because if you're not making
mistakes you're not trying hard enough
you know these things i'm saying they're
not unique they're not things that i
just thought up in some
some miracle growth you know things when
i talk to people in our company when i
talk to people about our company
i never have a unique thought i can't
remember i don't know that i ever did i
can't remember if i ever will or don't
expect ever to
there's no magic formulas to customer
service there's no magic formulas to
doing things right
these these sayings that you hear me say
are things that i've read elsewhere and
just regurgitate back but how many
people do them
you know we all know the golden rule do
unto others as you would have them do
unto you
and that's nice you know but do you do
it
but even more importantly than the
golden rule what about the lover's rule
do on to others as you would love to
have them do unto you
that's what we try to stress at micro
solutions that's what we try to use to
differentiate ourselves
not just to get by because everybody's
going to be nice
you know when you invite someone into
your house that is an acquaintance that
you like okay
you're gonna offer them coffee you're
gonna offer them a doughnut
and that's really what you expect you
know if you went to their house because
you're just acquaintances but when you
leave the house
it was nice if you go back fine if you
don't go back fine
that's the way customers look at
businesses if i go back fine
if i don't go back fine you know they
say that eighty percent of the people
who have a problem
tell at least ten people only 10 percent
of the people who had a good experience
tell
anybody and it's the same way when you
go to visit an acquaintance
and when people come to try to do
business with micro solutions i hope
i pray and i try to convey to each and
every one of our people
that we give them a reason to want to
come back
we give them a reason to do a good
morning wrap to say okay let's do
business with micro solutions
you've got to really concentrate to do
unto others as you would love to have
them do unto you
i'm working pretty hard and uh so there
are a lot of people
but i'm one of them my car is there
pretty early and it's
in the parking lot pretty late and on
weekends
so and i value my family time a lot
so i i'm pretty committed to this uh
and seeing apple turn around the company
i mean i started the company with steve
wozniak in my parents garage
you know 20 years ago and over 22 years
ago
and so there's a definite place in my
heart for this
i'm drawing a salary of i think a dollar
per year
so i hope i'm not burdening the
shareholders too much and
and i'm i very much want to see apple
get turned around
and i think it's gonna so i i don't know
how much more committed i could be if
people need these symbols well
one of the things that people do
instinctually when there are tough times
is they kind of do nothing
and and uh you know they they don't they
don't uh they kind of hunker down
this is so frozen rabbits in the
headlights yeah you know it's kind of
just just uh complete
stunned into inaction and i think that's
actually the worst thing to do i think
times when everyone is confused and
kind of stunned present you know the
most enormous
opportunity because nobody's really
doing anything so
you know i think this is a time where
the the seeds of
really successful new businesses will be
created in fact if you look in our
industry which i'm most familiar with
you know the greatest companies kind of
came out
of and were formed in some of the most
difficult times in the industry
when no one was really looking and
everyone thought the whole thing was
going to go
south all of a sudden a whole new breed
of companies uh
you know emerged so for example if you
look at
you know the when dell was formed in the
early 1980s 1984
this was a pretty dark time in the us
economy
the person computer industry had just
gone through a big down cycle
and the prevailing wisdom was that all
electronics
would be dominated by the japanese yeah
you know
and and that we had this big boogie man
called the the you know japan inc
and that no one could compete with japan
inc and
especially in something like computers
well it turned out to be completely
wrong
and there was enormous opportunity and
huge waves of productivity were
unleashed with the computer industry
you know flourishing you know we set up
three airlines
um virgin australia right virgin america
and virgin atlantic
and um and they've all been
very successful um and they've been
successful
um i think well i mean
most business is successful because of
the people but the people
uh only excel
if you give them the tools to do a great
job and if they if they feel lucky
and then so i think um you know what was
critical in virgin atlantic was that all
every single little detail um was right
so we were
you know we were the first airline to
introduce seat back videos
and five years before british airways
and
you know kids who traveled on on virgin
uh would not let their their parents
travel on any other airline for sure
they wanted to they wanted seat back
videos and
um you know we had stand-up bars for
you know upper-class passengers and uh
i'm sure lots of romances
started at our at our upper class bars
and we're not the kind of airline that
banged on lavatory doors either
[Music]
so what is your decision-making process
or
thinking when it comes to investing your
time your money your energy
sure uh it's very important because time
is the most valuable thing you have
is one make sure where you're putting
your time and energy
is something you want to do not just
because you're exploring with people you
don't like or a business you don't like
or a situation don't like time is so
valuable
try and speak if you're speaking to
people or a situation
to people you feel there's hope for that
you can do something with
to do something great not just make
money
whenever you go into business or in a
relationship with someone
just to make money then it means you've
already decided to take a portion of
your time to make these papers that are
backed up by nothing but will buy
stuff to call it a possession
we have all these great possessions well
if you have these great possessions
could you give them away if you had any
possession you could give it away
hey great it was a possession and you
moved on if you can't give that
possession away to somebody
just give it away then it possesses you
some people say everyone was born an
artist
and society their parents they be
they beat it out of them oh you know
there's times there was there was
someone after i said i was gonna run for
president
uh that showed me like a videotape of
somebody making me
making fun of of me about that concept
and i was thinking like wow if this
person was doing this from
my age of three i would have never been
me
and you know people say
geniuses are kids with good parents
so
how do you nurture the things that
people would call weird and
to something that could be considered to
be to something that would be
exceptional like
so many movies are based on
this anti-hero that's up against all
us doing the exceptional you know
anything you can imagine
probably is doable right you just have
to imagine it
and work on it and
things that we thought were almost
impossible so we we were interested in
machine translation uh there's
services on the web uh we had licensed
one that
which could translate between different
languages and obviously for search
you know if you can't if the
information's not in your language
we can't find it for you and most
information is not in your language
right this is sort of a by definition
and so we thought well be great if we
could provide search results from any
language for any query
and so we're really focused on that
problem and uh we focused on it and we
developed
google translate and we we found some
machine learning researchers and we said
do you think you can
translate you know between any languages
and do it better than an average human
translator
and they said they laughed at us they
said no we can't possibly do that
but they actually were willing to try
and uh
you know six years later we can
translate between 64 languages
and it's amazing actually we're better
many languages were better than an
average human
uh translating we do it instantly and
for free
and between those 64 languages we can
translate between any two of the
languages so we have something like 4
000
languages we can translate between and
so i'm just trying to give you i guess
i'm tremendously optimistic that
whatever things we try to
challenge whatever challenges we try to
to take on
uh we can solve with a little bit of
concerted effort
and some good technology and i think
that's a really exciting place to be in
the world
so i think we want more people working
on it we want to have more ambitious
goals
and i think with that we could easily
double kind of human progress and the
rate at which we're
we're developing what i want to talk to
you about today is
a note which i call daily so if you
create a new note
in your notepad or something that you
check on a daily basis this is the most
important thing
name it daily and then write the word
do colon
and then go down a few lines and write
the word don't
call on the one thing i would ask you to
do walking out of this
is to every single day just for a week
wake up to this note check it throughout
the day
and then also before you fall asleep
check to make sure that you did and you
didn't do everything so
what you put in each one of these is you
have a list of everything that you want
to do
every single day and you have a list of
things that you don't want to do and the
easiest way to add to the don'ts
is to notice something that you never
want to do it again you never want to do
again
and you just add that to it very very
simple i'm just going to share
some of mine these might be a little bit
personal and embarrassing but
here we are
number one on my do list is to stay
present
i think it's so easy to get trapped in
the past
it's so easy to think about the future
the most important thing is i stay
present and just reading this
brings me back to the present brings me
back to this moment
number two for me is be vulnerable
show people my mistakes show people
my fears because they can relate
because they're going through similar
things
number three drink only lemon water
and red wine
great red wine is a great modifier for
it
um this goes with one of my don'ts which
is don't drink hard liquor or beer
on weekdays
number three is uh six sets of 20 squats
and push-ups throughout the day i just
have to do them every day
uh six sets of 30 second planks
run for three miles meditate on this
list
stand up straight which whenever i say i
always see posture moving in the
audience
say hello to everyone i just bought a
heavy bag so i'm training with a heavy
bag so i want to spend 10 minutes with a
heavy bag every day
i'm going to do a video journal every
single day
and i want to get seven hours of sleep
on my don't list and again this is one
of the hardest things and
a lot of these are personal so i'm not
going to read all of them
but my don't list is don't avoid eye
contact
don't be late don't
set expectations for someone and not
meet them
don't eat sugar i'm on the paleo diet so
don't eat wheat
lentils or dairy and then of course
don't drink hard liquor or beer
on the weekdays um so this list while it
sounds very very simple
has been fundamental in establishing
patterns for myself
and it's something that i do check every
single morning i check
throughout the day and i check right
before i go to bed and i make sure that
i check
everything off and go through it i've
given it
to our companies i've given it to a
number of students that i've talked to
as we've
gone to schools and recruiting and
people have come back to me and said
that
this is something that works for me it's
something that's easy to do and
something
easy to remember one of the most
fundamental things about it
that i've learned that i've taken away
from it is how it gives you focus
how it gives you something that allows
you to really ignore
everything else that's going on all the
other noise to allow you to focus on
what's most important so
this do and don't list for people and
individuals in the company has
translated to a do and don't list
for our company for square we have a do
and don't list
we have these are the things that we're
going to do these are the core things
these are our bold bets and these are
the things we're saying no too for right
now has been
fundamental in allowing us to move fast
to continue to innovate
and to really push the boundaries and
continue
and question and and reset everything
that we think about the organization
well i would say i've always believed
that a strong mission statement's really
important and i have to say we've never
succeeded at it
it's like this odd thing you know we've
had them every year for 15 years and
they're constantly different and
now we're all so cynical we're like come
on we're trying to make people happy i
mean that's the fundamental thing is
in consumer service you know we're
trying to be better and
and us and disney and mission aren't
that different there's a bunch of
different tactics at it
um but we're an emotional product we
cater to the things that are
important but not necessary um and i
love that part about it because like
when you're selling
milk or penicillin you're selling
something somebody needs
and we get to sell something you want
okay that you choose to do
because it's really cool a human you
know to
uh be entertained and connect to people
over entertainment
and so we celebrate that a lot and we
want to change the industry but in terms
of
like a mission statement like so many
companies have uh
you know facebook talks about a more
connected and open world
um and then you see that phrase again
and again and again and it's a powerful
mantra
we don't have an equivalent and i think
we probably would have been stronger if
we do
in the early days um it was uh to
connect
people with movies they'll love and it's
okay but it's kind of like the long kind
of awkward phrase connect people with
movies that love
and you know it's just not punchy and um
and then so like we used it we had
t-shirts you know
and then it didn't really motivate
anyone didn't really stick um but we
knew we were trying to make people happy
with dvds and then eventually was
streaming and original content
yeah if you want to have impact uh
usually delegation's important um
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started i wrote most the code
and everybody else's code i read and
kind of rewrote uh
and that got us up to 10 people
and then i had to say to myself okay
we're going to ship code that i didn't
edit
and that was hard for me uh but you know
i kind of got over that then
i still said okay i'm gonna interview
everyone and i'm gonna
at least look at samples of their code
well that got us up to about 40 people
and that was at a point where i had sold
way more software
than we could write uh because everybody
was so
impressed and i thought well i need
to keep enough collect enough money to
you know keep hiring all these people
but uh
the demand was so high that you know we
were actually falling behind that's when
i hired steve
and steve figured out a uh
how to control what promises i made to
people uh
and b how to hire lots of people and
good really good people and create
organizations and teams so i delegated
to steve that
and he was constantly saying to me okay
we're going to hire programmers that
you've never met and i'd say no or not
and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint
wasn't going to work uh you know so uh
then i said okay then i would you know
know all the managers of the people and
so over time
uh and of course you know i could say
the quality per person was falling
monotonically
according to me but you know large
problems
uh if you want to you know write the
most popular
office productivity software that one
person
absolutely can't do that you can write
pretty code so
everyone has to decide what scale of
organization they want to
work in eventually you know my role was
very much as a leader
and a reviewer of managers but the top
people and i hired some super
experienced
people uh i would make sure they were
pursuing a common vision and they were
well coordinated
but in terms of a lot of management
stuff
they were way better than i was now i
had to have the framework
to know what mix of skills that we
needed and
you know when they were working well
enough together but
a lot of uh you know my
value adam was picking say to do
graphics user interface or to do an
integrated office
uh type thing or to go global and not
use agents to have microsoft be present
all over the world
and so yeah picking what you're good at
and how you find the other people
uh to fill in those things that's super
important and most founders
don't aren't able to scale that up and
kind of give up
the hands-on things that they used to
get a lot of
pleasure and comfort from during my
california springs and summers
i spent most of my days in the high
sierras in yosemite valley
working as a river guide and a rock
climbing instructor
i loved those jobs but unfortunately
they didn't pay that well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley i had learned a program
in college
i didn't love programming but it was fun
and i was good at it and computer
program
programming gave me the same kind of
satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life i thought i was
making real progress on my journey of
self-discovery
i had found a cause i had a couple of
jobs that i love
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing
foolish things she wanted me to work
full time as a computer programmer
or go back to college and finish my
degree
we compromised sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember
was a sailing class taught at berkeley
marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said this was the single
stupidest idea
she had ever heard in her entire life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out and then she divorced
me
[Music]
this was a pivotal moment in my life
[Applause]
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time i was not disappointed in
myself
for failing to be the person they
thought i should be
their dreams and my dreams were
different
i would never confuse the two of them
again
my father started reliance
with a hundred dollars right
when i joined reliance in 1980
the market value of reliance was
30 or 40 million dollars and
in 30 years the opportunities that were
provided
by this country has enabled us
to create wealth for india
my father was a big believer that
any business that has the
sole purpose of making money is not
worth doing
right business must serve
a larger societal purpose the alliance
raised all its money from capital
markets
and from individual small shareholders
so we've created a million millionaires
just by investing
in reliance out of ordinary indians and
that is the process
of creating wealth for the country
once you create opportunity
wealth comes and you must be consistent
when you try a business and you start
you might have hiccups here and there
but it does not mean that that business
is not going to work there must be
challenges
in fact what i keep saying that life
without challenges
is very very boring so if you have
challenges you just have to know how to
work out or how to work around these
challenges and you will be successful
once you are consistent
what business does it like is for you to
try something and then once you have
one or two problems now you want to
change and move into another business
that doesn't work in business at all you
move to california you actually
start a law firm and then practice law
for some period of time
i had no alternative
and then you actually had an army of
children almost immediately
i painted myself in quite a corner yeah
so zero choice is pretty powerful yeah
for sure yes of course
so so you practice law and then you
leave law
in the firm that you helped found and
move over to
investments well but
help us understand that that sounds
miraculous
in fact it was rather interesting i
probably got
paid about 350 000 in my first 13 years
of law practice
total and i had an army of children
and no capital to start with and
when i
[Music]
chose this alternative career i had over
three hundred thousand dollars in liquid
instruments so i had and that was 10
years of living expenses
so i was not a courageous venture some
admirable man i was a cautious little
squirrel
saving up more nuts than i really needed
and
not going very deep into my pile of nuts
and so that was it wasn't that
courageous and i kept one foot in the
law firm while i tried my capitalist
career
but as soon as the capitalist career
succeeded i intended to lift that second
foot
because i recognized that the potential
of law practice
as i saw it then i didn't anticipate the
boom that came to the big firms
uh i just saw it as being
more difficult i wanted more
independence than i was going to have
as a lawyer i hated sending other people
invoices and
needing money from richer people i
thought it was undignified
i wanted my own money not because i
loved
ease or social prison i wanted the
independence
the people you hired defined the culture
whether you like it or not
so larry and sergey when they started
the company said we need to have really
smart people so they hired a rocket
scientist
and they hired a medical doctor and they
hired a
stanford graduate who had been a
professional football player because
they figured that they wanted
normal people who'd done something
exceptional so in my case i was a pilot
and i had done other things and they
said okay you're good enough
you know the ceo has to have something
besides being a ceo
that makes them interesting and everyone
had something i would go around and i'd
say
well what's special about you it's like
it's like sesame street you know what's
special about you and what's special
about you but there was always an
interesting story
so another lesson i learned is that you
don't hire generic people you hire
people
who've had some kind of uh of stress or
achievement or whatever
the best people hire by the way are cfos
who've gone bankrupt
because boy have they been through the
war and on the cfo's
on the cfo side and the finance side you
want somebody who's
not going to happen again and you only
go bankrupt once by the way
who is an entrepreneur where everything
is a smooth ride and you go through
these things and i'll tell you and you
get criticized and you have to have a
thick skin
yeah yeah and you've been there i've
been there
and by the way you don't you don't buy a
thick skin
and you don't even know you have it
until somebody starts to uh try to
puncture it and then you discover what
you're made of
uh building a company and you guys are
doing great for 15 years
um have you sort of like fundamentally
disagreed on something at all
or over the last 15 years and how did
you how did you resolve
uh where do i start
no you know i think if you
get to know somebody over a long period
of time we're working together for so
long and we
you know are committed to doing that you
don't like get
agitated about one little thing or the
other i know we
work it through and also generally we've
gotten
to think uh remarkably alike
which scares some people around us i
guess yeah and the other thing i mean we
know enough
i guess that when we're disagreeing i
mean you make a lot of calls that aren't
obvious so i mean if you're disagreeing
it's probably that it's not obviously
for uh building a company and you guys
are doing great for 15 years um
have you sort of like fundamentally
disagreed on something at all
over over the last 15 years and how did
you how do you resolve
uh where do i start
no you know i think if you
get to know somebody over a long period
of time we're working together for so
long and we
you know are committed to doing that you
don't like get
agitated about one little thing or the
other i know we
work it through and also generally we've
gotten
to think uh remarkably alike
which scares some people around us i
guess yeah and the other thing i mean we
know enough i guess that when we're
disagree i mean you make a lot of calls
that aren't obvious so i mean if you're
disagreeing it's probably that it's not
obvious what to do
every day you have a choice every day
you have to decide who's going to show
up today
is it going to be the you who settles
who stays comfortable
who does what everybody wants you to do
who just is afraid of scared
is unwilling to do the things that you
need to do to go off and accomplish your
dreams or
is it gonna be the bold version the
courageous version the one who believes
that you can create something that
nobody else around you believes is
possible to create
that's a daily battle even for me it's a
daily battle
we wake up and have to fight ourselves
every day
because no matter how great a day you
had yesterday no matter how bold you're
feeling today
tomorrow is a new battle it's a new day
and with time yes you can raise your
baseline so that
what a morning feels like is not as bad
as it used to be
but the decision to be bold courageous
unstoppable is a daily battle
for everybody the difference what makes
a difference the difference between
the people who wake up and then go off
and doing amazing things
and the people who just stay small and
stay stuck knowing that they're capable
of more the difference
is that successful people demand
excellence from themselves
every day and it starts with having a
morning routine that sets them up for
success
what is your morning routine now some of
you may have a morning routine you may
be thinking oh not another morning
routine video
listen if you're not feeling bold and
confident every day
your morning routine is not serving you
and you might have the best morning
routine of anybody that you know you
might be the only person who's working
out every morning or who's
watching a video every morning or
spending any kind of time
on themselves every morning because most
people wake up like an accident
most people wake up check their phone
start responding to other people's
emergencies and never spend any time
building the life
or the person that they want to build
right that's most people that's fine
that's not you
probably if you're watching this video
you're subscribed to this channel that's
probably not you
but it doesn't mean that your morning
routine can't serve you better
the acid test for a great morning
routine
is do you feel bold courageous and
unstoppable
every day after finishing it
[Music]
a lot of people just go through the
motions a lot of people watch a video
like this while they're
making breakfast or cleaning the sink or
doing something else
you're not focused you're not paying
attention
you need to because if you're not
focused and paying attention to what
you're doing in your morning routine
you're not getting the feeling that you
need to feel at the end of the morning
routine
i don't care if your morning routine
takes you five minutes or two hours do
you
feel bold powerful unstoppable
courageous at the end of it if not you
need to fix it
now what makes a routine get somebody to
feeling bold powerful courageous
unstoppable is different for different
people
right the thing is let's switch my hand
here getting tired
the thing is everybody has something
that makes you feel
that feeling you felt it before and what
it is for me
is always going to come down to service
and feeling like the work that i do
matters isn't important so the thing i
do in my morning routine is
i always share a daily message and so go
to my instagram and i'll share a daily
message
and i remind myself that what i do
matters it serves people
it's having an impact right if you woke
up and felt like the work you did every
day
was going to have an impact you'd be a
lot more bold courageous
and willing to take bigger chances and
so that's what i try to do every single
morning
but what works for me may not work for
you that's okay
the good news is you felt bold you have
felt courageous you have felt
unstoppable at some point in your life
the problem is it's just not consistent
so what is the thing
that you did that you experienced to
help you feel that level of boldness
where you felt like you were capable of
doing things greater than what you're
doing right now
what what happened what experience were
you were you watching the video were you
listening to podcasts were you doing an
act of service were you sharing a
message were you
talking to your mom like what were you
doing were you meditating naked with
your cat outside i don't care what it is
right what did you do that made you feel
bold
powerful unstoppable and confident and
then how can you inject that into your
daily life
every day so you start every day with
that thing
as a reminder for you to go off and live
a courageous bold powerful life because
what you're doing now is tiny compared
to what you're capable of
and chances are there's nobody in your
life who's pushing you
like you need to be pushed you're
probably the person pushing other people
to do great things
and other people in your life they may
not be supportive they may be supportive
but even the ones
who are supportive even the ones who are
supportive
are not telling you this thing you're
doing is great
and you know what you could be doing way
better man
like this is small compared to what
you're capable of
the people who are supportive
[Music]
they love you they're chewing you on but
there you think you're great their
version of greatness
is tiny compared to yours and you know
it
it's awesome to be seen as great in
their eyes but you know you're capable
of way way way way way more
and that doesn't happen if you're waking
up every day and just feeling okay
if you're waking up every day in doubt
in fear and insecurity
and that's how you show up to life you
cannot allow yourself to show up
every day in life feeling insecure
cowardly
small scared afraid little
it's a choice and it's easy to stay
there by default because our head
keeps us afraid
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love them continue to believe
i'll see you there you should just be
yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said
i was just going to be myself i find if
i don't get enough sleep then i'm i'm
quite grumpy